all right so now to the nation's fight
on covet starting today nearly 100
million americans are free to get a
covet booster shot the cdc director
signed off on the plan last night the
decision means there is a booster policy
in place for all three vaccines in the
united states pfizer moderna and johnson
and johnson drugstore chains say they
will have those shots available starting
later today meg oliver has more
in a unanimous decision a cdc advisory
panel cleared the way for millions of
eligible americans to receive booster
shots final guidance from the cdc allows
moderna recipients who are 65 and older
or adults at higher risk from covit due
to their health or working conditions to
receive a booster six months after their
second dose it also greenlit boosters
for any johnson and johnson recipient 18
or up two months after their shot the
cdc is also encouraging americans to get
whichever brand of vaccine is available
opening the door to mixing and matching
vaccine technologies what do these
boosters mean for us long term in
fighting this pandemic we have to be
really clear with the public that for
now we know that they can have a
tremendous impact on these breakthrough
infections michael osterhome is an
infectious disease expert at the
university of minnesota he says anyone
eligible for a dose either a booster or
a first shot should get one we're going
to have to be vigilant realizing that
we're not done with the surges even in
the united states we still have 65
million americans that could be
vaccinated by our current
recommendations that are not
we have to continue to emphasize the
importance of getting them vaccinated
dr osterholm told us it's not clear yet
if another round of boosters will be
needed in the next few months but these
shots are critical in preventing
breakthrough infections and saving lives
nate meg thank